you are just your career has blown up in
such a satisfying way we're all so happy
for you thank you yeah and and now
you've written this book and it's a
great story because of all the success
you've had you're very much in touch
with how it wasn't always great you know
you started out and you work really hard
yes I came to Hollywood it by the way
thanks for staying out appreciate that
nice one the other guests it is nice
when they stay out you're gonna regret
involving him so yeah I came out to
Hollywood in 1998 and I moved into the
st. James apartment right in the
epicenter of Hollywood and I was really
excited my first morning I'm making eggs
and I open up the curtain and I face the
building and there's a guy having sex
with his couch locked in on me wife
having accepted this yeah so um welcome
to Hollywood of course I called home and
I told my Italian mother she's like come
home forget it just scrap the whole idea
so yeah every time I open up the curtain
this guy would be either full-frontal
looking at me
I lived in the dark for six months right
did you ever ask anyone about this guy
yeah I went downstairs and they're like
oh yeah it's Paul he's harmless I'm like
harmless I can't even go out my balcony
I have a cup of coffee without this guy
it was awful yeah feel bad good a couch
yeah
you